ce soir là les clients du stonewall inn
un bar gay de new york ont riposté
répliqué à la violence policière
trois nuits d'émeutes l'étincelle qui a
enflammé tout un mouvement pour la
défense des droits des homosexuels
c'était pas une époque où c'était
c'était facile de de revendiquer ses
droits surtout qu'on était comme les
gens qui collaborent des personnes
extrêmement marginale j'ai décidé qu'on
avait à l'époque l'homosexualité était
une honte perçue comme une maladie
plusieurs emplois était interdit aux
homosexuels danser entre personnes du
même sexe était illégale porter des
vêtements qui ne correspondait pas à son
genre pouvait mener tout droit en prison
le stonewall inn était le des rares
endroits où les gays les lesbiennes ou
les trans pouvaient s'afficher quand la
police a débarqué et que les gens ont
résisté
les choses ont commencé à changer c'est
vraiment la prise de pouvoir d'une
communauté qui était écrasée par un
pouvoir coercitif d'une manière abusive
un an après les émeutes des centaines de
personnes ont marché dans les rues de
new york pour crier haut et fort la
fierté d'être guide n'est la répression
n'a pas cessé pour autant
notamment au canada malgré la décline
asa sont là en 1969 au canada il ya eu
en 67 des descentes des balles dans le
bar trucks
près d'une décennie après les émeutes de
stonewall inn la police de montréal
arrête plus de 200 personnes au bar
crocs la majorité est accusé de
grossière indécence ce qui soulève un
élan de protestation dans la métropole
ça a été très long c'est tout ce
processus là après 2,2 au bain
finalement peut-être qu'on allait droit
on peut défendre nos droits
aujourd'hui dans des centaines de villes
du monde
on célèbre la fierté la diversité une
fête devenue familiale mais qui a pour
origine les nuits d'émeutes du stonewall
inn ici vincent maisonneuve radio canada
montréal